salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi c'est
donc le jour des astuces je vais vous
donner un pouvoir le pouvoir de résister
aux manipulateurs et pour ça il faut
identifier les sept principales
techniques utilisent des manipulateurs
faut quand même admettre une chose c'est
que l'on manipule tous un moment donné à
partir du moment où on essaye de
convaincre quelqu'un il ya aussi une
part de manipulation une manipulation
très courante c'est celle de la
précision celle des chiffres des
statistiques et ça crédibilise tout de
suite un argumentaire je pense que 80 %
des gens qui vont sur youtube ne regarde
pas la télévision le problème c'est
qu'il le pense c'est tout c'est très
fréquent de donner des chiffres qui
sortent de nulle part la parade pour ce
genre de manipulation c'est juste de
remettre en cause ces chiffres en
demandant d'où ils viennent mais pas
dans la démarche de le piéger et n'en
juste pour votre information en numéro
deux il ya quand même le changement de
sujet qui va de pair avec la mauvaise
foi qui est donc de quoi en tournée le
problème imaginons que je demande à un
pote pourquoi il m'a toujours pas ramené
mon livre que je demande depuis un
moment et que là vraiment j'en avais
besoin en bon manipulateur qui est mon
ami il devrait me répondre quelque chose
du genre t'es pas ramener son livre mais
tu te trouves ça normal toi que julien
et mais pas ramener mes dvd à un moment
donné ton livre tu me l'a prêté depuis
un mois lui je vais prêter les dvd
depuis six mois tu imagines attention
manipulation dès qu'on essaie de vous
détourner votre sujet initial c'est pas
bon pour ça la parade est très simple
c'est la technique du perroquet
reformuler répéter mais ne le laissez
pas vous emmener dans une autre
direction que celle que vous avez choisi
au départ ma réponse aurait été par
exemple de dire oui effectivement c'est
très long mais revenons-en à mon livre
pourquoi tu me l'a pas ramené recentrer
le débat technique de manipulation
numéro 3 le fait de voler la possibilité
de quelqu'un de très utile quand
quelqu'un veut vous imposer quelque
chose de faire semblant qui peut vous le
prendre c'est une technique que
connaissent très bien les commerciaux
vous voulez acheter un véhicule
d'occasion une voiture un scooter peu
importe le vendeur vous dis ah ouais
mais là faut venir vite parce que j'ai
eu un appel de quelqu'un d'autre qui est
sur le coup et
et est ce qu'il existe vraiment en fait
ce mec ça vous créer un sentiment
d'urgence en fait comme si on pouvez
vous prendre quelque chose alors que
peut-être vous aviez juste appeler pour
vous renseigner sur le prix juste ça et
là d'un coup ça devient une priorité la
voir avant l'autre à parade c'est juste
de se contrôler et mentalement à ne pas
se laisser parasiter par ce genre
d'information et quand ils arrivent de
savoir les détecter c'est déjà une
parade en soi et ça ressemble d'ailleurs
à ma quatrième techniques de
manipulation sur laquelle il faut se
méfier celle du faux libre arbitre si je
vous dis par exemple vous êtes
complètement libre de ne pas vous
abonner à cette chaîne vous êtes libre
de tout les regarder sans vous abonner
après ça c'est vous que ça regarde il se
crée un petit truc bizarre de
manipulation on vous dit bah oui mais au
jeu aussi libre de m'abonner si jean
millet bam manipulation soyez très
vigilant sur toutes ses phrases qui
commence par tu es libre de la parade
c'est la vigilance la cinquième
technique allé très très maligne quand
elle est utilisée par quelqu'un sait
qu'il a mûrement réfléchie c'est de
créer une série de huy pour aboutir à ce
qu'on peut imaginer j'appelle un pote et
je lui demande de venir me déménager
dans une heure avec sa voiture pour
faire tout le monde et ménages il ya de
fortes chances que lui trouve une excuse
pour pas le faire parce qu'il n'a pas
envie ce qui serait bien normal
d'ailleurs on prévient pas les gens une
heure avant pour un déménagement surtout
que j'ai besoin de sa voiture et j'ai
besoin qu'il porte les choses lourdes
mais je peux l'amener à une série de huy
qui lui fera valider ça au final sans
qu'il s'en rende compte puisque quand
une personne a commencé à dire oui à des
choses simples
elle a du mal après à dire non ça
devient complètement illogique dans le
processus dans mon exemple pourrait très
bien appeler mon pote pour lui demander
de me rendre un tout petit service dans
une heure de passer chez moi pour
m'aider à descendre la télé je peux pas
la descendre tout ce que j'ai peur de
l'abîmer donc est ce que tu peux venir
je vais à dire oui c'est quasiment sûr
mais moi je sais déjà qui viendraient en
voiture une fois qu'il va être là et qui
va commencer à descendre la télé je lui
demandé de descendre deux trois autres
objets et puis pour qu'on aille plus
vite peut-être de descendre les cartons
comme ça on sera deux à descendre les
cartons ans apprend que ça prend quoi
petit te rend plus rapidement et au fur
et à mesure de tout ça je vais lui
demander si on peut pas faire un
aller-retour avec sa voiture parce que
ça m'aiderait beaucoup en fait comme
j'en ai pas et que tout est en bas tout
le piège se referme les wii continue
d'affluer d'avancé et un moment donné il
peut pas dire non parce que c'est plus
logique en fait ça plus oussad moins ça
ne pèse plus dans la balance il y en a
déjà trop fait la parade c'est de savoir
dire non au bon moment c'est dès le
deuxième round 2 attention je t'ai dit
oui pour ça mais par contre pas pour sa
place
zoom techniques de manipulation à
laquelle on fait le plus souvent face au
quotidien c'est l'appel à la loyauté ou
à la compassion et la défense c'est
d'être fort il faut absolument être fort
et stopper ça tout de suite ne pas
admettre admettre ça c'est vous auto
manipuler sinon un exemple très concret
un jour j'ai une petite embrouille à
quelqu'un que je connaissais à peine et
cette personne là m'a appelé au
téléphone pour régler ça ce qui était
très très bien de sa part et dans la
conversation cette personne-là me dis
enfin fabien tu me connais tu sais que
je suis honnête je mens pas dans son
argumentaire je considérais que c'était
une technique de manipulation donc gelé
stopper tout de suite en disant non non
par contre la star est je te connais pas
je te connais pas comme tu le dis je ne
sais pas si tu es honnête et je ne sais
pas si tu me ment pas c'est toi qui me
dit ça je te connais pas assez en tout
cas pour dire ça alors évidemment ça l'a
déstabilisé mais au moins on a pu
discuter et je n'ai pas souhaité
admettre que je considérais que cette
personne n'a été honnête puisque en fait
je la connaissais pas on s'était croisé
qu'une fois et ça m'amène à la dernière
technique à laquelle on fait le plus
souvent face qui est la technique de la
garantie la parade
elle est très facile il suffit de
remettre en cause cette garantie
exemples concrets quelqu'un qui vous dit
je peux t'assurer que si on fait telle
chose alors on va obtenir tel résultat
c'est sûr au lieu de chercher à savoir
s'il a raison pas où au lieu de dire oui
directement demandé de vie pourquoi il
est sûr de ça quel est son argumentaire
pourquoi t'es sûr qu'on aura ce résultat
là je t'écoute les techniques de
manipulation comme celle là j'en ai
référence et plus de 150 elles ont
toutes une parade il faut les avoir en
tête
on les utilise aussi nous même parfois
sans s'en rendre compte en fait qu'on
veut convaincre quelque chose c'est bien
de pouvoir y faire face et c'est bien
aussi de pouvoir se contrôler ou du
moins savoir ce qu'on fait si vous avez
trouvé cette vidéo utile vous pouvez
d'ailleurs mettre un petit pouce en
l'air pour le signifier ça c'est pas une
manipulation c'est votre liberté
on peut aussi se retrouver dans la
télévision directement à 20h50 sur la
chaîne numéro 23 il ya les dossiers
surnaturel qui passe d'un spécial sur
l'hypnose le mentalisme etc
je suis dedans et si vous le regardez
vous pouvez mettre un petit h tag team
menthe à l'eau sur twitter hashtag team
menthe à l'eau ces lâches attaques ont a
décidé tous ensemble samedi lors du live
/ lesure périscope n'hésitez pas à
l'utiliser sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on
puisse tous retrouvés les conversations
qui a eu c'est donc à 20h50 sur la
chaîne numéro 23 n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner rendez vous demain à 17 heures
pour le prochain mentale blog ciao